it's 11am at the riu club hotel resort
on Gran Canaria for the last hour
professional host Yuri slay slay on
Gonzales has been putting a group of
vacationers through their paces after
some stretching she moves on to a 30
minute aqua aerobics lesson Yuri as her
friends caller was born in Cuba she's
lived on Gran Canaria for around eight
years she works at the four-star resort
five days a week pero primero que nada
la energía que la porta khadi a lot my
work is all about energizing the guests
I'm constantly talking to people don't
no problema and I like to convey as what
Aviva that's the most important thing
positive energy and good vibes not
everyone can do that you have to be a
certain type to do this kind of work
moonta grado en tu trabajo para poder lo
transmitter a low clienta despues
this sort of hotel tends to attract
families a team of hosts is a big draw
for them
many people book a stay here because of
the wide range of activities
the resort is in mas Palomas one of the
most popular destinations on the island
tourism is ground canarios most
important industry Yuri has worked here
for four years now one of her main
duties is maintaining a good
relationship with the guests ivailo but
this hotel is just perfect that's it
from what we've been coming here for 13
years yawns every year we come here and
we just feel great at twelve-thirty it's
time for the rehearsal for the evening
performance those who do this job have
to speak several languages and be
physically fit the job also requires
acting and dancing talent Yuri's a
trainer dancers so that part comes
naturally but it still took her a while
to grow into the job flower on the
busier than of them but when you start
out the job can be stressful you think
oh god I have to do this then I have to
run to the next thing once you get used
to it and have fun with it is no problem
you find a rhythm you prepare activities
leave them eat lunch go home to the
evening show then it starts all over
again y su casa de la heart un poquito
rizzardo noche a ser hecho with a minor
after the rehearsal the team meets to
discuss the upcoming activities there
are 17 hosts working here the hotel
chains activities director Gerhardt
krotz followed from Austria is
responsible for recruiting and training
the team he knows exactly what kind of
people he's looking for difficulties
Johanna fleets they can't be shy they
have to be friendly and talented when it
comes to our evening shows they can't be
nervous on stage or when they've got a
microphone in their hand they need to be
outgoing missile off is at at three
o'clock the team gives a small
performance by the pool and lets the
guests know what activities are planned
for the afternoon
for URI leads her next activity she
shows us what some of her colleagues are
up to while Maria from Spain is doing
strength training Nina from Germany is
in the hotel's art studio helping guests
to get in touch with their creativity
a few meters away a Dutch colleague is
doing the same but with younger guests
at half-past three Furies working again
this time she's giving a salsa class
Yuri lives off site she's also a mother
and that doesn't leave her much time for
herself I'm Yoko halacha Sione's boy
when I go on holiday I go somewhere
where there are no people don't they
don't they aware that then I can have
time and space for myself either the gun
men somewhere quiet where I can relax
with no stress of course I love partying
and excitement but that's not what I'm
looking for in my own holiday pero
cuando de vacaciones mucho lo contrario
las Yuri he's dinner at home then she's
back at the resort at eight-thirty in
time to prepare for the evening
performance
one of the whaddya nadal aha I do get
tired after a typical day of classes
looking after the guests and generally
having a lot to do SI pero nada but at
the same time I still have energy and I
look forward to the performances go God
ya know I love my job so it never feels
like a chore so hacer lo hago muchisima
Ghana poke me encanta
tomorrow at ten o'clock it starts all
over again Yuri will be back making sure
the guests have a holiday to remember